all right all right can you hear me
yeah i can hear you
let me switch things around
all right can you hear me now
yep all right
oh i'm so stressed man
just give me a couple seconds guys now i
gotta send
forte the correct link
all right so let me go and redo this
okay i apologize for everything going on
i know it's been chaotic uh i will
figure out why my stream what's funny is
i'll stream just fine parky and the
reason the moment i do the attic show
it's like okay now now we're gonna mess
up you know we're gonna be fine
every other time but we're gonna mess up
now because we're doing the attic show
yep all right
i apologize for that you know hopefully
you guys find your way over here so
anyway welcome to the attic show past
president future of gaming you guys know
what it is i got dirt
griggity over here what have you been
playing sir
well i've been playing a couple of
things actually how do i sound because
they said i sounded low on another spot
i guess i'm probably fine on stream yard
um
yeah i i
i've been playing you know actually the
connect
i bought a connect off of ebay
and uh we've been playing you know on my
old 360 the family's been enjoying it uh
but besides that i've been playing um
the dark anthology the was the dark
picture is it dark picture enthalpy
anthology yes yeah those super massive
games i've been loving those games i
just finished madame madonne i finished
a little hope now i'm playing a house of
ashes those games are incredible and
those and the graphics in those games
don't really get the props they deserve
i guess maybe because it's like maybe a
point-and-click type of games but those
games are beautiful man
i actually think that um
[Music]
um what's the game they made on the
playstation 4 um until dawn until dawn
is one of the best apps you know type of
those cl
point-and-click adventure games that's
ever been made like it was fire it is
such a good game yeah and it's it's
enjoyable all right so
appreciate it for coming through like i
said
my uh i had something i had something
divine prepared for you guys
but now
we we we sprawling man we sprawling
that's fine uh
for those of you that don't do youtube
and stuff
like stuff like this happens all the
time so i'm not gonna really like stress
about it too too much we got a five
dollar super trap from uh
from drawing tj what's up attic and
hargy appreciate it and then we got a
five dollar super chat from the angry
therapist
shout out to dirk
what's up bro
all right so
what we're going to do
is i have a little bit of a formula
we're going to do on here now forte's
supposed to be here somehow
i told forte a week ago he we were
talking he was like yeah but i was like
definitely come on do the prediction
show and he ends up in lucas podcast
it's like it's like he was on his way to
mine and tripped into someone else's
i don't know how that happened
i'm just gonna be real with you forte i
don't know how that happened
uh but you know it is what it is we're
going to
keep it going and keep it moving so the
first thing we're go we got a two dollar
super chat from drawing tj
what's up dirt
what's up bro how you doing man first
thing we want to talk about
is obviously the xbox but that's the
event's prediction we actually have some
uh
i would say this is one of the most
important e3s that they've ever had well
it's not e3 but you guys get what i'm
saying and i know that that is said a
lot and i'm not saying that it should be
said a lot i think what people need to
realize is
there's been a lot of reasons for other
games in the future to be successful
uh in other companies in the future to
be successful but for this particular
moment this particular time
the reason i feel like this uh this
particular event is extremely important
to microsoft is because
it is going to probably determine the
next two to three years of hype that
generates in the play in the xbox series
x and i think you're going to see more
of this going on uh let me get these
super chats real quick uh because i know
once we start this thing we
need to stop
fight i'll switch off from flight i
blame halos surprise multiplayer launch
in november for the technical issues of
this podcast always love you have some
fun
yeah
you know they do be blaming halo for a
lot of things here lately don't they
don't they agree
they blame me for everything
all right then we got five dollars super
chat from drawing tj everyone hit that
like button i appreciate
the support of the podcast you guys all
right so
first thing i want to talk about is i
kind of want to keep it a little bit
contained i want to still talk about the
predictions but i want to i want
everyone to have they shot because you
know what annoys me the most harji is
when you do a prediction show of people
and everyone takes all your stuff
so what we're going to do is we're going
to bounce one at a time throughout the
the panel uh and you know
uh hopefully we don't take hopefully
everyone's been so original there's no
one taking no one's stuff i doubt it
though i doubt it i seriously doubt that
so first thing we're going to start with
we're going to start with har geek
because he came in on the last minute
guest
uh and you know oh i'm sorry hargy i've
switched between the uh uh the two
events
please tell these people where you're
coming from i could not believe i forgot
to let you
give your intro it's it's been a crazy
day yeah so harget from uh game on daily
and uh see i guess the things i've been
playing recently just finished track to
yomi
um it's very good and yeah it was pretty
good i didn't mind it um
and let's see i played uh kirby a bit um
and
what else was i playing i was playing
something else uh what was it oh wild at
heart because it was leaving game pass
um so that was one of the ones that i
find i'll try it out and it was okay
it's fine little indie game uh and then
i started san andreas gta standard i've
never played it and it's also leaving
game pass so i just started that
so
nice long game there uh and in between
that i've been uh playing a little bit
of yakuza like a dragon trying to get
through that story so uh those are the
games i've been playing
all right so you know what we're going
to talk about like i said we're going to
go from one person to another i do i'm
going to snatch a little bit of that
salt from iop's format man uh there's a
couple things i do want to bring that we
do that in that show that i'm going to
do that here but we're going to start
with harget cheney what is
one
particular
announcement that you hope personally to
see at this event
so like i i still think they need to go
full uh tilt in that game past third
party stuff and so i'm hoping there's a
big like
triple a game that comes in dan date and
my hope is it's gonna be the one that
just announced with warner brothers
gotham knights i think that would be
just awesome like bring that in day and
date into game pass
all right so uh just to clarify you you
feel like
they need to really focus on the day and
date and uh i think so good big game
right especially like june is going to
be the rollout right around when they're
doing their showcase for spartacus right
so you want to have a massive
announcement that no our place is the
place you want to be forget spartacus
right and something like that is gonna
be well i think i think i'm sure they're
thinking about that right so i'm looking
for that obviously there's gonna be the
microsoft announcements of their own
games obviously that's all there but i
think the thing that they need to do is
focus on that third parties bringing
those triple a you know day and dates to
showcase that you know this is the place
you want to be because we're not only
bringing our games there's a massive
library but also those third-party games
that you want to play
okay so um
what about you dirk because i with you
it's a little it could be anything man
it could be anything what about you
you know what i gotta be honest um
i am a huge fan of the wolfenstein games
and
we you know we don't know for sure yet
but we're hearing rumors about
wolfenstein three and i'm assuming that
they have to announce something i mean
because they are doing andy allen jones
but at the same time their last game
came out what is it 2017 was the last
wolfenstein then they had that little
expansion
um what was it called blood something
i don't remember the name of i didn't
really care for it young blood yeah i
didn't really care for it but that was
in 2018 so it's been a few years um they
still say they just started working on
indiana jones
maybe last year or so
so what were they doing in those years
so i'm hoping wolfenstein 3 gets
announced and it gets announced as the
xbox exclusive that's what i'm hoping
for sir
love the franchise
i feel like
wolfenstein would be
i feel like there's enough time that's
went by where wolfenstein would surprise
people because i think a lot of people
automatically assume that they've been
working on
uh indiana jones this whole time and if
they have been working on indiana jones
this whole time that all right all right
where's indiana jones exactly that's a
great point yeah
it's been a while since what like 2019
2018 was when that expansion came out
and i don't believe the full team worked
on that expansion
so technically 2017 was was
wolfenstein two
came out
yeah that's five that's why i do feel
that
if they weren't working on wolfenstein
and keep in mind indiana jones now it's
like what a year and a half two years
ago
it's been a minute i believe they
announced the early 2021 i believe yeah
so i mean we
we're coming up on
a year and a half most likely yeah
pretty much yeah so that that's why i
personally feel like there's a good
chance
that
something has been working on this
entire time
i don't i don't just see or war a world
where they're only working on one game
and it's been indiana jones i i do feel
like even if it's not
the game even if it's not wolfenstein
did they just sit around and do nothing
that whole time
absolutely i agree with you
wholeheartedly
oh so it's it's look look who look you
came on in look
then i looked at the clock and i was
like oh man it's five o'clock
all right so let's
let let's let's ask
forte
what is the one
announcement that you particularly want
in this event not the one that you think
is going to happen not the one
that uh you know no mike drop moments
just enough an announcement that would
gauge your interest
that would truly gauge my interest
um what i would like to see is a
continue i would like to see
the continuation of uh halo single
player i would like to know what
direction that's going in i would like
to know when the next dlc drop for
that's coming i don't think it's going
to happen anytime soon because i do
think
that um multiplayer and forge and other
stuff take present but if they did come
out and say something about halo still
because i was actually truly invested in
the single player i really really
enjoyed it
and um i actually played that before i
even played any multiplayer for the most
part so i'm really really looking
forward to seeing what they do with that
especially if you played it and beat it
and got to the nsc like the end credits
and stuff of how the game or how it
played out of stuff i definitely want to
see
what that is even though and i think
that's years away until we get to the
resolution of what you saw at the end of
that um
the game but that's what it would that
would make me be like oh
they're paying attention because i think
there are as much as people love and
want multiplayer and co-op campaign and
stuff to come into the game
this is going to be a long tail when it
comes to the single player and i would
love to see some type of information
around that and then that will kind of
just set the stage for the rest of the
show for me
i agree i i think there's uh
i think there's a good chance something
like that happens here's the thing when
it comes to
any announcement related to halo
how serious are they with the halo brand
right now like are are they more worried
about
having
let me get rid of this phone
have they are they more worried about
having some type of
energy going into like the multiplayer
because i know right now they're getting
destroyed for that so i'm curious that
that has took away some of the resources
from like the story element of halo
i'm curious on that do you guys think
that or do you guys think that maybe
they're still
you know going in
the way they originally intended to
because i feel like
the way they launched was good in terms
of gameplay but a lot of people feel
like it's lacking in terms of content do
you feel like that maybe they'll okay
let's let's pull these people that was
originally gonna make us some story
content let's make everyone work on this
multiplayer that's gonna theoretically
keep the game alive
um well i don't know if that's such a
great idea i think i like the single
player content especially in that june
showcase i don't know if they you know
like multiplayer you just need to keep
doing all the time right that needs to
be constant engagement they should have
like monthly cadence of here's what's
coming here's what's coming here's
what's coming because otherwise you're
just going to lose your player base but
this is a good time to showcase that i i
like forte i like yeah let's bring in
that's that campaign what's next you
showed that cliff anger what's next
what's next what do we get right is that
10 years from now or is that coming next
year is that coming this year like
that's i want to see that that i think
that june showcase that's for that
single player content that you want to
see what am i going to be playing right
it's great that we already have the
multiplayer but yeah i think that's at a
different venue even if it's like the
para
we're assuming it's going to be a paris
shore
there's gonna be issue with paris lily
right so
that that might be a good place to have
a you know joe interview hey what's
going on with the multiplayer right
let's bring bring that home too but uh
but i'd love to see that single player
stuff mm-hmm yep i agree with you yeah i
i feel like the only thing that's ever
gonna truly bring back breath into the
halo brand at this point
is a massive expansion to the single
player that has a lot of multiplayer on
top of that and i think forge will help
but man like
like three four three you own all like
you own all the raw xbox does but you
own all the rights to the halo franchise
why is it the pit been dropped in here
why hasn't guardian been dropped in here
like to me i'm not a developer and i'm
actually going to bring a developer on
here to explain situations like this but
to me
it shouldn't be too hard to have these
maps remastered and put into the game
like maybe maybe like four content
creators can do it in a couple hours and
i'm not saying it's that easy but forged
content creators can make duplicates of
guardian
in a blackout in a couple hours you mean
it to tell me that what 800 people can't
do it like i don't know exactly the
semester the semantics and everything
going over there but it's just like i
feel like one of the biggest things that
could really gravitate and give them a
lot of pull is to have a lot of maps hit
the uh hit the
the this
the game classic yeah
i agree with that
all right so uh here's mine let me get
these two super chats real quick we got
a two dollar super chat for frog boy x1
gaming
will be will there be any checker birds
at the uh xbox show
what does he mean by that he talked
about like
like checkerboard yeah
making fun of your place
they never they they always extra man
yeah we got a two dollars
nina uh xbox br announcement
all right let's talk about that real
quick do you guys think there will be an
xbox br announcement at the showcase
next month on the 12th nope
hey yo let me say this um and well going
off of what jazz gordon said he said it
has been in development for two years
and it possibly could be released this
year if that's the case
absolutely of course but we just don't
know if that's really the case so
my honest opinion i'm going to say yes
forte i'ma say yes final final answer
final answer
final answer yes absolutely want to put
your michigan card on it that's right
i actually feel like that could get some
[Music]
uh some movement
uh like honestly oh it definitely get
movement but it's also gonna come back
to the conversation
are our is their priorities in the right
place
like it's not that i don't think it
shouldn't come because i do think it
should come
but it's just like the whole
the whole thing with um master chief
collection even knowing that dlc was
being worked on all that stuff was being
worked on in you know conjunction with
you know the halo infinite stuff the
fact that that released on that platform
for pc and on console still was like a
black eye for halo infinite
and the conversation still was oh three
for three prioritizes the older game
than they do the newer game
so
even when it comes to like br
yeah it's cool it's there but where's
the co-op where's the where's the
multiplayer everybody doesn't like br
even though i'm br is the most popular
thing i do think they won't get as much
flack for a vr being brought to the game
like all those other things
uh but i do think it will still
be a conversation that 343 is
prioritizing the wrong things because a
lot of people you know started their
love of halo in single player and i i
personally know a lot of people that
haven't played the game because they
don't play by themselves they play it
with other people so you're kicking the
cam further down the road on that too um
if they're saying that it's something
that's going to launch over the summer
then yeah that's probably cool too
but i think they if they're going to
announce vr they're gonna have to have
some type of update on where all the
other things are happening with the game
two at the same time basically just to
give people updates on it and then i
think they'll be perfectly fine but if
they just say br is coming oh yeah just
be ready for the next day all of the
project creators talking about it and
it'll just be a it'd be a crazy mess
so i don't i don't think it's coming on
yeah i don't know
because like that announcement for
certain affinity was in what april right
when they said oh we're going to work
more closely with 343 on halo and that
was kind of the genesis of us
understanding yeah working on this if
they said that they were like ready to
do it you'd have a different message i
don't think they're ready like it's it's
too much so if it was coming at the like
fall time frame okay maybe but do you
think like microsoft has been burned
enough of saying oh we think it'll be
ready let me go ahead and announce a
date i don't think they're going to do
that until they know it's damn well
ready to go
and that's another thing too do you want
to release do they want to really
release a mode because if you because
right now you're in a mode that anything
that releases for halo has to be perfect
almost has to be pristine because of
just the cloud that's over it it's like
well did
yeah it's such a microscope but it's
like you know you you want to make sure
that's good and the fact that this last
season came out and you got them already
saying like oh yeah we learned this we
learned that and you know we're going to
do better with the next season but the
new season just started so you're going
to fix this season over the course of it
to get everything the way it needs to be
can you imagine them releasing the br
and having that same kind and that's
inherently that's probably going to
happen because we all know when you
release something something especially
as substantial as that there's going to
be issues when it first comes out but
you at least want to minimize that by
giving people the things that they want
that they've been waiting for
that will give them a reason to
if the br isn't working right they can
go play something else because that's
the main reason why i haven't played
halo infinite i logged in i played it i
was like oh this is cool
but i really don't want to play this and
then when i went to go play the stuff
that i was playing back in january i
realized that it was the same and i was
like i don't want to do this
so
let me ask you guys a question all right
so we're going to go ahead and move away
from the halo thing because we've got a
lot to yeah
wow sir i like your helmet i mean your
helmet i like your your um
beanie yeah your beanie
can i get one thank you for helping him
with that thank you
all right so i want your [ __ ] clearly
i have told you guys yeah i got the
naruto [ __ ] i know we eating eating
those noodles out of that bowl let's go
so clearly you know i asked you guys
what do you guys want to see
something that you as individuals will
like to see from here now what i want to
ask you is what do you think
xbox needs here like what is that one
announcement that
xbox needs here and if they don't have
here it's automatically going to be a
not necessarily a failure or an l or
anything like that just very
disappointing we're going to start with
forte oh man you would start with me man
what they need to have here
huh are we eliminating like the the
things like starfield because we need
yeah i mean don't don't i mean you can
say something basic but don't be
basically literally because literally
that's it it's like honestly everything
else is kind of up there
um
it's it's almost easier to say
what would what do you think they're
gonna show that would more excite you
and get you even more invested in the
things that you not because i think
starfield the whole show rides on star
field no matter what i feel that's the
game that everybody knows um
but i will for you i would love to see
fable finally the game has been talked
about for three four years at this point
now has been a super secret that was not
the best kept secret for five so at this
point i think that if they were to show
something around that but i think if i
had to say the one thing that would kind
of break the show outside of starfrail
is not showing hellblade you didn't
already showed it once at the vgas you
show a cinematic gameplay trailer last
year at the vga now it's time to just
show straight gameplay so i think i
think that game needs to be shown this
year and i don't think it's a make or
break for it but i do think that that
game needs to be shown this year because
you didn't already shown it on two
separate occasions but don't wouldn't
you couldn't you make an argument uh and
i'll get to dirt i want you to answer
this couldn't you make an argument
because they've shown
okay let me ask you a question what was
the problem what was the biggest problem
that and i loved hellblade was my game
of the year that year
what was the biggest problem everybody
had with hellblade this is a walking
sound well it's a the fighting in it is
not
exactly the fight the combat yeah so
once they show me what the combat looks
like okay then i'm good because they can
show me cinematic trailers and all of
this stuff and or cinematic gameplay
with just the aesthetic of the game we
already know because you're invested in
the story already because you love what
you played in the first one you love the
voices and stuff in her head we need to
know what the combat looks like so until
they show me combat so maybe that's
probably what you're asking i need to
see combat from hellblade if i see con
black
combat combat then we're good but they
need to show that at the show
okay so
you feel like the the combat for
hellblade is essential to show
the improvement from the original one to
this one this one that this game is
going to do better and try okay
dart what come come on man what do you
need that you think they need to see on
that or you feel like the show is
automatically gonna be a disappointment
i'm not going to use the word
disappointment but yes you use it
if they don't um
in my opinion have shown some release
years at least
if they show hellblade 2 and they don't
have a release year like 2023
that will kind of be disappointing for
me if they show some game player
contraband they don't show a release
year or a vowel i just want to see a
release a year like i would like a date
but i'm not going to go that far yet but
at least give us a release a year
because the last couple of e3s
uh last year i thought was a damn good
e3 but you know we still didn't get a
lot of release dates
or even release years so
we know they have tons of games in
development a whole bunch of stuff in
development but now we're at the point
where we need to get ready you know to
see some of these games like when
they're dropping i love the road map i
absolutely love the road map but i would
like to see yo
oh cool hellblade 2 is 2023 evolus 2023
contraband is 2023. i would love to see
that like at least for the games that's
supposed to drop next year at least
okay so okay so just to clarify
uh you feel that
microsoft has been very relaxed on the
release dates and they need to be a
little bit more maybe not necessarily
street dates like this coming out this
day but yeah you need at least but now
do you think we should we should ask for
like a time of the year like winter
summer or do you think a year in general
is fun
uh time of the year will be great
but uh
i'm not even asking for that right now
just let us know the ballpark of when
these games are going to release you
know just something because we haven't
had
like with the exception of star field
we haven't got that in any game for the
most part cause you know we're assuming
forza forza motorsport is going to be
there we're just assuming that
um you know we're assuming some of these
other games are going to be there but we
haven't got any type of release dates
for anything besides starfield
okay so
let me actually add a little a little
salt onto your uh nut salt some sauce
onto your uh
response all right so now you said you
want release dates
for games
tell me three that you think is
essential that we
absolutely need solid release dates or a
release year three games
and i want it from hardy and forte i
want it from hargie and ford okay not
from dirt
no no no four i want it from all of you
that's what i'm saying
okay
well i mentioned them already uh since
we already have starfield release date
like
locking stone
hellblade 2
evolved
and for me
um
contraband
because i we don't know anything about
the game i'm assuming we're going to see
some actual gameplay this year we've
heard they've been developing this game
since 2018
so those are the three games that excuse
me
i'm expecting
some type of release dates
and i actually feel like you're being
really realistic with those games what
about you hargie
what are the games that you expect to
see some release dates at this event
well
um all right so release dates i mean so
i i like the idea of a vowed i think
that one should should be it's been
announced for long enough uh they did
announce so many games in that like july
showcase
and that was like a couple of years ago
now it's like come on like one of these
things coming if you're gonna announce
them
um
but i guess if i want release dates
um
what i'm excited for i want fable um i
want a vowed
uh and then
i want i want to see what that indiana
jones game looks like but that one would
be the other one that uh that can excite
me i'm kind of interested in what that
one is so i'd love to see a release date
for that
as far as like you i don't know if you
want to ask my one thing that like that
they need to have you don't like the
dates that's a fantastic one
let's push that back a little bit
because i want to get forte's three
games and then we'll move on to your
what they need to show yeah three games
that
so actual dates
no no no just release windows like a
year window i would like summer spring
that's me that's me being green that
that's me saying microsoft i don't care
what these people i want
okay so
i'll give you so let's just talk about
well we already know we're getting
starfield this year i think we're gonna
get a release date for
forza we're actually gonna get that this
year i think we're going to get a window
because i don't think um
red falls coming out this year i think
that's coming out next year now oh
really so i think we're going to get a
release window for that for the
beginning of next year
i think we're going to get a actual date
for um
hellblade i think we're getting a date
date for
next year i think we're gonna get a date
for that next year
and i also think we're gonna get a
window for a vile being 22 end of uh
holiday 2023.
i think you're going to
get a valve release date and hellblade
release date yep and a floor is a
release date i think like i would be
very surprised if you had to get those i
would be very surprised so hargy all
right so let's
what is that one thing that you
personally feel like has to be at
the microsoft show
so besides the dates which i agree with
i was going to say that but
my other one would be
if i were to let dirt keep talking he
would probably take your next one too
[Laughter]
um
but the other one that i want to see is
like the the end of the show uh needs to
be something brand new like just just
give me something that so you're never
about drop moment yes exactly exactly
just something that's like a teaser
that's gonna be three years out that's
fine but
that's just
gonna blow my mind oh cool i gotta have
this but like the wolverine trailer
right yeah just tell me something like
that mic drop boom all right that would
be fantastic
somewhere near the end mic drop there
you go
fantastic
this one would just totally kill you
it's a superhero game
they bring out any i don't care whatever
i iron man or superman i don't care
something something crazy just bring it
out
but you wanted to have the same house as
you said so just to clarify
you feel like a very strong ending show
is what they need something that is
going to remain on people's minds going
forward okay oh yeah okay so
i forte did did you say what you what it
needs to be
yes i know we gotta we're okay first i
feel like
i'm going to still a little bit hargie
says but i do feel like and it's not
just the ending they need a strong
opening and strong closing and i feel
like because those things if you mess up
any one of those things
the middle is going to be forgotten
right it was a couple years ago
yeah so i i feel like
there is a good chance that we'll see
uh you know you know we're not going to
go into that because i want to get your
general predictions here in a second but
that's my thing you need a strong
opening and a strong closing most likely
i would say open with star fill close
off a new ip
agree hold on that's how i would say it
i don't think they should close with
starfield
has already been shown they need to open
with starkville i agree with you
wholeheartedly start off with star field
in with a brand new ip i i love that
idea right there yeah last year did they
end with
like game play of forza was that what
the last thing was no it was rightful it
was rare
that's right it was it was worse it did
fall and to be honest with you that was
a horrible mic drop moment i'm sorry
i thought they should have just ended it
with foreign
i don't think you can end it with
starfield because there was no game
there was if there was more substance
you could have ended it with starfield
but they can't i'm with geek that they
definitely should end it with a new ip
yeah because i feel like that's going to
gauge the most interest now the only
exception
is that they end it with a classic game
that people want like a fall at new
vegas 2 or something like that that's
going to generate height
huh you're going to end with elder
scrolls
dude that would be a little killer if
they could actually show like they are
literally going to end i'm telling you
so
it's super in pre-production they showed
us a
they showed us a trailer
of something that could have been
anything that just put elder scrolls
over the top of it
i think they're literally gonna end that
show with something
that'd be pretty good i think if they if
they even if it's a 10 second clip
they're going to end it with a 10 second
three minutes
maybe a dragon coming down out of the
sky or something we'll see see the thing
is is dragons are in skyrim because
that's the lore behind that region that
they're in yeah i'm gonna be right with
you the next one we're gonna talk about
i'm gonna go first because of that
nonsense you just said is what's one
thing you don't want to see at this damn
with it i don't want to oh that's easy
elder scrolls at all i don't want to
even smell why
uh because it doesn't look because
no hold up hold up hold up we can fight
that's fine but i'm strong man you want
that
they have star filled in here they have
a vowel most likely i feel like star uh
i feel like elder scrolls sticks will
just
it won't it would take away from
everything it won't take away but let's
say
that's what the end of the show is
supposed to be though but we've already
seen elder scrolls six no we have it
years ago we've seen something we saw a
man
that could have been oh that could have
that could have been
like it would have been anything
so just to clarify you would like to see
a cgi of star uh no no no no no no no no
not a cgi
it don't even have to be it just has to
be it could be a pre it could be a
render it could like i say it could be a
five second render of the show something
in the game
and then at the end of this show it's
elder it says elder scrolls on it but as
long as we get a chance to see something
other than what we saw before because
guess what that would
the internet would blow up yeah all
right well we're going to ask knowing
there will be xboxes
tell me if i'm if i didn't put anything
on it yeah tell me if addicts bugging
that they should take time out of their
busy schedule
to show a game that they've showed years
ago
and they're not gonna have any type of
game play whatsoever they're not gonna
have any type of story related stuff i
don't think it's going to do anything
they show here's
don't listen they are
they are kings of the western rpg they
need to dive deep into that
let people know what they're doing i
don't know but here's the thing
you act like they're not already doing
that well i get i get what you're saying
the only thing i would agree with you is
if they come hold and they say at the
end of it
xbox console exclusive exactly that's
what yes one of the reasons why people
will go home happy like oh my god
people are
but to me you're already celebrating
their next game without letting their
game they're coming out but they let
them know yo after evolve we got some
other bangers on the way hey including
elder scrolls six boom now what happens
if they end the show with like a gear
six tray i'll be happy with you i'll be
happy with that too yeah i almost think
i'm trying to you've already lost your
privileges
i also think if they don't okay so even
if we go with them not in any show with
that
what if they when ty howard's after
talking about uh starfield and he says
and i got one more thing to show y'all
and then he just shows you that at the
end of the at the end of the um the star
field presentation
it fits nicely right next to it i just
don't want them ending with it that's
all i'll give you that because i think
what you end the show with should be
something substantial enough
to like
[Music]
let's roll back a little bit all right
because we kind of went a little bit
actually could you be incognito today
let's okay so
dirt what is something that you do not
want to see at this event like if you
see at this event you just like you know
you know that one thing like vr is it to
me i see vr i'm disgusted
what is that one thing to you that if
you see you're going to be like looking
at your phone like sitting there is it
over yet is it over here mr addict sir
this is a very easy question um is it
minecraft
see if he's in damn grounded i'm every
i understand sea of thieves is
successful i understand grounded is
successful
stop every show they show both of those
games
i understand they have content coming
just drop a youtube video of it
now okay hold up hold up okay
let let's let's break down your
statement a little bit now let's say
remember
the video game awards they had a
pre-show
now if they showed all that during the
pre-show that's fine would you be okay
with that okay okay we're getting
somewhere dirt we're getting there ain't
got to watch it
i'll be fine in the pre-show yeah show
up grounded new new content show off sea
of thieves new dlc whatever but i'm
tired of seeing both of those games for
the last two or three shows
sometimes you don't want to keep seeing
the sound you basically just gave them
the right to show you uh minecraft then
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you said oh you don't want to see those
but he'll take minecraft i hope not
all right so let me get these super
chats real quick before we get a heart
key we got a five dollar stream trap
from ds skill town i predict dirt will
play the halo theme on that piano you
know what's funny
i thought that was you a legit house
like
i wish my house looked like that
i don't know where these people live
like i don't know where everyone he got
me one time i had to look and i said
wait a minute we live in the same state
and it's bright outside yes
then we got a five dollar super chat
from the angry therapist md jet set
radio that'd be an interesting
interesting announcement interesting an
outfit yeah that would but i wouldn't
really do anything people like yeah cool
okay i don't think it's i don't think it
would be meant to do anything i think it
would just gauge oh my god like like
kind of like just like
wow factor you know shout out to that
man's avatar because the transformer
game announced by them would be amazing
oh is that megatron megatron that's
megatron
so we got a five dollar super chat from
king arthur what up though the bad boys
deep on the attic show and hargie the
god two
let's get it i appreciate it man i
appreciate it then we got a five dollar
super trap from the rubber knob i reckon
they will end it with compulsions new
game
nice i did not expect i'm expecting not
to be there too i am [ __ ] be there
he'll be there too
uh then we got a two dollar super shot
from mr irishman vegas 2 will end it
mark my words you guys want to see
fan boy
let that happen
like you'll be that or you know how
you'd be seeing these these reaction
channels with these unrealistic
reactions they'll be like getting up oh
my god
so like that's yeah that's totally me if
something like that happened i i would
be that dude i would be that dude then
we got to find out a stripper from
apollo cooper in the middle they should
talk about the mini uh the project
maurya that one more thing should be
either doom 3 elder scrolls 6
or new vegas 2. um you
i forgot about that bro
yeah i forgot about that man i did too
and then we got a two dollar super chat
for omni z x or z yeah z no x
mandalorian picking up the baby jodah
just a shadow
then we got a five dollar superchat from
restored by life will xbox ever design a
next-gen controller who was this guy who
was the dude you will get a you will get
you know what that's a good question
when do you guys think we're going to
get the uh see the redesign for the next
uh elite controller
it could be at the show because that's
what i was thinking like could we get
the series three hmm that's the hey
that's a good foundation you know they
always they always have a controller all
right so
let's talk about general predictions
that's right there's a lot of general
purpose targeted
yeah what is something
that you don't want at this show at all
i'm with you on the vr like that stuff
is just like i think it was um but
if uh
the thing i don't like seeing the thing
that actually slowed it down a little
last time was dlcs coming out or like
yeah i don't know expansion for this is
like i don't okay that's nice but i want
to see new games show me the games
like show me some trailers and gameplay
like this thing has dlc that's nice like
i agree better for that like paris joe
hey we expanded this game like that top
gun thing that's cool show me in that
show i want i want just awesome this
year so just show me the games
so i agree with you it's terrible but
it's the part where i start to like lose
interest
so do you guys think that
because they have a lot more
announcements and i assume a lot of
these games are close to me and done
that they're going to refrain
from showing
games that's already out there do you
guys think that's a thing
i feel those games that are successful
for them
they're going to probably announce some
type of dlc that's why even though i
said on like cfds i do not want to see
that they still might show the next big
cfds dlc
i agree i feel like because
these games are close to being done
we're probably going to start seeing
them not
because look look
when you show cgi
most the time that cgi gonna be not too
much of the show
it's gonna be a minute maybe a minute
and a half but when you start having
gameplay to show that's gonna take more
time yeah so what do you do to padded
that show that's showing a bunch of
cgi's yo we got this wasteland dlc we
got the star uh this see it do you see
it i feel like that's why you've seen a
lot more than um i've actually felt like
inside xbox needs to be the outlet for
these games you have a chance to bring
it back
see they need to bring it back
but they need to let other people run it
like this
because here look i i love
major nelson jeff rubens i love maldef
but
i feel like marketing people and pr
people running a show dedicated to the
audience
that's not going to work out because at
the end of the day
they're designed there
to keep our expectations of their
company in check so i don't feel like
you're ever going to truly
you know
get that type of audience happy because
like some things we think is cringe and
i think the cringe stuff's okay
but if you have the content to show
that that cringe is okay people are
going to overlook the cringe
no one talks
when they did the flute man a
playstation
no one no one really goes on about that
because there was some fire god of war
and goes to shema stuff that that week
so there wasn't a lot of talk on the
cringe but when you when you go to these
shows
and you don't show
your stuff in a good light and then you
know sometimes you have devs come on
that don't really seem like they know
what they're talking about
like they'll talk about game pass
they don't even know their games in game
pass remember that happened a couple
years ago they were talking about game
present that dev didn't even know their
game was in game pass oh why not
i don't remember that it was something
it was something like that maybe it
wasn't that exact scenario but it was
something that when you were listening
you're like man like really so that's
why i do think we need something like
inside xbox but i think it needs to be
done
differently like i
you can make it community focused but at
the end of the day the whole point of
that show is to show us content
and i feel like it's always 25 content
75 community and it's like can we have a
50 50 show man like no one likes state
of place but people still watch them
but it is what it is okay
forte tell me that one thing you don't
want to see at this event
uh
i don't want to see a
five minute or more segment of people
talking on stage
i don't want to see a two-minute segment
well i'll give i'll give
our lord and savior todd howard the you
know because he's the only person
because i know he's going to do it
once the show starts though
once the show starts at the field does
his monologue at the beginning because
he's gonna do it and we love phil
i don't want to see it again except for
todd howard because i know ty howard is
going to do it but there should be no
other segment where a person is up on
that stage speaking for longer than
180 seconds
i got something even better for you
what's what you got i don't want to see
no corny cringey
gameplay of the whole team playing the
game on stage oh my god oh yeah
i don't want your division
you don't need to put it on there
because when you show stuff like that
and then you actually play the game and
you're like yo i never experienced
anything remote close to this
i could say one time they've done that
that actually i really was messing with
it was that first real big
rainbow six siege trailer remember how
they had like the multiple panning and
they're going in the house i like that
that was a unique one but they weren't
on i don't remember them being on stage
like that remember i don't remember that
because it was like remember they all
came out they're like side by side
playing the division
i don't want to get out of that they
keep that home keep them people home
it's pandemic anyway we don't need them
people in the same way
all right so
now we're going to move on to just
the basic announcements that you feel is
going to be at this event we're going to
start with haruki shini what is
something that
we all know that's gonna be there well
you know just your your average thing
now we could talk about the xbox dude
because the xbox stuff we all know
that's gonna be there and how you expect
it so what i really wanna hear from you
from you guys is
where how much of a presence do you
think starfield's gonna have do you
think it's gonna have like a huge
gameplay presence or you think it's
going to give a story orientation or do
you think they're gonna try to do both a
vow want the same answer from that if
that is there in hellblade if these
games are there what kind of presence do
you want from them
um um okay so
so the obvious things that are going to
be there i think forza is there right we
we got the big hint with the developer
right the lead like he told us oh it's
not supposed to say that's coming so
so we can pretty much assume it's coming
right so
uh so i think that's gonna be there um
red fall i
i hope it has some sort of release date
in the next six months right something
uh so i assume that's gonna be there so
that should be a pretty easy one
obviously they're gonna do starfield and
to your point of
what will they show well there's also
the other one right there's the uh
keeley show
uh summerfest games whatever he calls it
right yeah
yeah the summer game fest whatever they
call it whatever he calls it i i have a
a feeling that that's going to show up
there too
so i don't know what is going to show up
there that that comes up first
so there's gonna be some sort of thing
and i think starfield should would
probably end up being there to attract
the general audience to xbox
right so i'm gonna guess that that's
gonna be the game they showed they did
halo last time
i think they're gonna do this one it's
gonna be starfield
and okay what they show i don't know
it's i don't think it's gonna be the
full reveal they're gonna say hey tune
in to the xbox show to catch gameplay
right so it's gonna be something like
that i'll be my guest right so it'll
probably be a bit more of a uh trailer
type thing right just cinematics and
then it moves over to
you know gameplay reveal probably with
like a howard sit down interview going
over here this is why we did this
so that might happen or they might do a
bit of that and then do something at
like a paris show to go like 30 minutes
or something like whatever 20 minutes of
star field like in depth or maybe it's a
whole separate segment but yeah i think
that's what it would end up being so i
would expect anywhere between like 10
ish minutes uh to 15 minutes at most in
the in the
the the june showcase and then a
probably two minute to three minute
trailer that'd be my guess in the game
fest thing something along those lines
because i think they're going to want to
have that you know wider audience from
keeley right so i think it's going to
show up there
okay so uh how do you feel about this
forte do you feel
that uh because i i think this is the
biggest
question mark in here is microsoft's got
so many tools and they shed
but which ones are sharp enough to bring
to the show
um
so i think um
what will be there i think hellblade
will be there
i think um
[Music]
he'll be there i do think compulsions
game will be there
i do think that game will be there
i also think that you will see a vowel
i think a vowel will actually be there
showed
and everything it it a lot of that
really is contingent on like you said i
do think there is going to probably be a
lot of blow around the medieval theme
because yeah we're not medieval but just
the rpg thing because that's what xbox
has a lot of right now
um so i do think that too but i do i
really really truly think that they're
gonna well i know forest is gonna be
there that's a given cause that's coming
out this year
uh but for something that's coming out
next year i truly think you're going to
see fable this year i think you're going
to fan out i think you're going to lose
your mind and i think you're i think
we're going to get a update from attic
literally 20 minutes after the show he's
going to go live before the iron lords
even get a chance to go live again and
he's going to have to talk about it
let me let me say this i'm telling you
right now
they're going to show you play a fable
you think it's game play i think it's
game play i think they're going to show
me a game player fable
you won't even have to worry about what
iop is going on
is is going to stop going live i'll be
hosting that
i'm hijacking that podcast if that
happens does the cog is no longer the
host at that point okay i'm the host of
that show this is this is oh yeah look
i i agree i don't know if we'll see
fable i think that might be a little bit
too that's the reach but i i do think i
think that's like a michael jordan
reaches different types of reaches
space jam
well it depends on which space we're
talking about here that there are some
that are better than others yeah yeah
the jordan one was much better yeah but
i i don't think it's really a reach
though because i think in general
possible they've been talking about that
i mean we knew about that game
two or three years before they even
announced the developer that was working
on it yeah
and they've been they've been hiring
like crazy for different design
philosophy for people that's working at
the studio and stuff
i think they're in a state i don't think
it's in a state for like it's like
playable from beginning to end yet but i
think there's at least in the states
where they can actually show you and if
anybody
is ready to show you a vertical slice
and they need to is xbox i know
developers don't like breaking out
vertical slices that are you know made
for these type of events but i do think
microsoft's in the situation with xbox
that they need to start showing a lot of
this stuff because
they have all of these studios but we
don't we we know what they're making but
we haven't seen it and i think fable is
one of the big ones
so let me get some of these super chats
while
while they post in there
they they
are hardcore
defending you today forte every time you
say something forte can't be wrong
all right so we got a five dollar swoop
drive from alvin how great would it be
if we get the street fighter 6 revo to
let people know it's multiply also
starfield will be in the middle of the
show that's interesting he said
starfield will be in the middle of the
show
we are going to have a segment towards
the end of the show on the direction you
want the show going to be on but it's
going to be interesting uh if they if
they make that choice uh then we got to
find out a snoop shot from d skills
town will there be a surprise game pass
announcement available during the show
maybe elderly
um
we're going to have a thing about that
too on what kind of game pass games you
have we got like three segments left
guys um so then we gotta find out super
chat from big cloud gaming salute to my
brothers i appreciate the support guys
all right so
uh first off i put in the chat i says
game is fable gameplay going to be in
the event yes no no gameplay just cgi uh
it looks like uh 39 saying yes 39 saying
no
22 say no gameplay just cgi i would be
very surprised if if that's in there
like i would be very
very surprised that that's in there
and that's just my uh personal opinion
on the matter all right so
let's go to dirk rickety
what is the the basic stuff you expect
to see in this and you know like i said
what how much do you think we're going
to see a star field of vowed hellblade
just their games in general yeah
obviously um starfield will be that
showpiece i think they're going to have
like a 10 minute trailer
of gameplay not like gameplay how it
used to be at e3 where someone is
standing on stage with a controller no
they're going to have a slice already
prepared with todd howard doing the
voice over right
yes so you see this so so you know you
go to space and this is the plan you
know stuff like that
um
i do expect like forte said hellblade to
be there with with some more gameplay
um but i'm going to tell you guys a game
that i think they're going to have there
um
with some like a small little gameplay
i believe perfect dark would be there
you would be perfect
hold on let me know
i thought forte was reaching now
let me sleep
okay
let me explain you this is mr fantastic
reaching by the way yes yes it's
definitely reaching
richards out here
i believe they're going to have a
small
piece of gameplay now i remember e3 and
not e3 i'm sorry the video game awards
2020 when they first announced it yes i
am reaching i am reaching but
i believe it's possible that
they could have some gameplay for
perfect dark i'm not saying there's
going to be a lot of gameplay now i'm
assuming the game is probably still a
couple years away just like maybe fable
is probably a couple years away
but i think they're going to have a
little gameplay for you
let me i think that would be uh very
good
uh so
android though right
what's the name of that what what's the
name of that game that um what's the
name of that game that rare is making
that no one knows what the hell never
wow yeah you got a better chance of
seeing that wow oh my god like microsoft
has like a standard right they don't
show game play until a year before
release right so i don't know if that's
going to happen
reed richards
yeah i said readers i read richard
if they
please invite me back on and i want an
apology oh you don't get an apology i
will i will make a i will make a little
dedicated um twitter video and apologize
to you on there hey
you saw ladies like you already like one
percent positive about this no i'm just
saying yeah
if they did man i'll be like god they
gotta make this dang video
i do i do like somebody in the chat that
did say state of decay 3.
yeah yeah we're about we're about to
hold super chat actually so we got a
five dollar super chat uh from drawn tj
i want to see stated of the case
i love to see you too
but i think the audience ready for the
disappointment we might see perfect dart
before staging k3 i'm gonna be real mad
i think if you if you're ready to see if
you want to see state of k3 you're gonna
be disappointed because it ain't gonna
look nothing like that no you know what
would be crazy yeah if they show perfect
dart state of decay three
man
wait wake out of next year
yeah
man being what do we think about how
it's gonna come out
stayed in k35 2025 oh oh well i'll say
2024. i'll say it's only 24.
you think it's just like fable i'll say
2024 for faber also yeah
yeah i think fables literally 2024. um
i really hope it's possible for xbox to
reveal a new game and include gameplay
with the reveal
that
shouldn't really be too much to ask for
who does that though who who reveals a
new game with game play because that
would assume the game is going to come
out within the next year
um
[Music]
got to work
nintendo does that
yeah it does it feels weird though
they're not the standards
they're the exception listen listen you
see
you see
metroid
nintendo's goats out here man lords of
the ninth yeah but their games don't
take
five years
but they sell 45 plus yeah that's a fact
my brother that is the fact that i mean
that matters that planet like that is
the fact that they did it was uh with
spider-man god of war and uh uh and
gears of war five i feel like gears of
war five
came out the year after didn't it it was
announced it came out the year after it
was announced 2018 it came by 19. yeah
someone said there's some gaming beyond
a box yeah
here's my thing
i think that we're gonna see game play
on
let me un snap that i think we're gonna
see game play
on
star field avowed yep forza yep
and hell played and red fall i think
and
they've got to show us the game play
real quick they got to show you that
game was supposed to come out this year
why did they open with red fall okay
we're getting here in a second okay so
star filled i think we'll see five to
eight minutes
i think we'll see
i think uh starfield and vaude are the
ones that's going to get the biggest
portion of gameplay now
there is a ball that avow doesn't come
out at the first three or four months of
next year so we might see a vowel
gameplay next year and that might be
what they
what they really push next year but i
for some reason i got a feeling that
that game's coming out like the first
three or four months of next year
i don't know we'll have to see because
star field i think it's come about six
months after star feel
but i don't know we'll have to see
exactly how that works i think we're
gonna see compulsions game yep and i
think there might be a chance
compulsion ends with their game
could be there there could be a chance
with that that's a solid chance yeah
that would be interesting brand new ip
yeah you're right about that that's just
like dead planet said
it'd be interesting if they announced
compulsions game and it comes out next
year
so it's going to be interesting i think
we're going to have a very
weird show than we're normally used to
i
i have a feeling that the second most uh
gameplay will be forza it's just my
guess because i think they're going to
want to show off the xbox and what can
do yeah i think that might end up being
the other thing
and racing games just do that well
yeah agree okay so now let's move on to
game pass we all know game pass is going
to be here in some way it's going to
yeah there's no way it's not going to be
here yeah i'm going to go through the
panel
and you tell me three games that you
always say a game that you feel is going
to be announced as a game uh day and day
a game that you
think they need to make as a day not
even a day game just a game coming out
that's coming the game pass doesn't have
to be in day and day and again uh so
tell me a game that you feel is going to
be in game pass and tell me a game that
you personally feel microsoft needs in
game pass for regardless if it's you
know for any type of reason could be any
type of reason that you feel they need
that in-game pass
we'll start with we'll start with harkie
hargy tell me enlighten me so
could we also ask this question how many
of the games they announced during that
showcase will not be in game pass
only about one or two you're right
you literally worry
yeah we can we can all say one or two i
don't think so
i already told you one that i think they
should put in game pass and that was
gotham knights right
um
what would be fantastic right from uh
uh xbox perspective not from like me
personally perspective is bring those
japanese games in that everybody wants
it aren't in there if you say persona is
coming in it's coming at xbox and day of
date it's in game pass boom
that'll be an interesting little you
know mic drop moment right that that
kind of thing so something like that or
ff7 remake
that has not been coming to xbox okay
suddenly we got it boom here it is in
game pass
man i could just see hargy right now
they say he just drops pin
all right so so darn
tell me a game that you want to see in
game pass in a game that you feel like
microsoft should have in game pass for
any reason
you know even though we don't know much
about this game it it might not even
come out until 2023 but
i feel that game what is the callisto
protocol
i believe that's a game that
should be in game pass um it's you know
they said it's like a dead space
type of game um like say we don't know
much about it we haven't seen any game
play but the game
should be dropping pretty soon that's a
game i would love to um
see in xbox game pass because it's going
to be a big big um third-party game i
don't know how it's going to sell but
kind of like back for blood you know
even i don't really care for the game i
thought it was a pretty good
announcement that that game was dropping
in game past day one so this is another
game i feel that would you know be
pretty dope to be in game pass
now
i was going to
capitalize on that so
i i i get what you're saying on that um
i don't know me personally i kind of
want them to
limit like future future games you know
what to say like i kind of want games
like within six months if that makes
sense
yeah
yeah so yeah i got you well the game is
supposed to drop this year but
probably not
but uh that's just the first game i
could think of because they really
caught my interest you know when they
showed it off last year or whenever it
was um
you know
they have some great games already
dropping the game pass this year like
gaming beyond a box said atomic heart
they have plagues tail requiem dropping
um
i'm trying to think off the top of my
head what other game
well i love them you know like besides
gotham knights i i can't really think of
any offs off my head besides the color
store protocol
um now a game they need
we'll probably be gotham knights
who got tonight they would need no
i don't think it's going to happen i
don't think it's going to happen
[Laughter]
that's going to just further the
conversation
game passes where your games go to die
wait a minute
i mean the game doesn't look that bad
though huh
that looks dude you watch it
it looks okay i'd rather i'd rather take
the glasses when you watch that i'd
rather take this
i'd rather take this for breeze right
here and just spray my eyeballs with it
like that before i do that it looks like
i i think what it is is when that comes
to that type of like a comic book hero
kind of game
i want to see a traditional thing and to
me that feels like we're just trying to
make a game and throw two people on a
map and just let them have fun on the it
doesn't seem like there's substance
there now i could be wrong we don't see
it now when i see something like um
uh the justice league game same thing
but what but they have shown they have
done a good job showing that game
showing the reverse evil flash or the
evil flash in general and showing that
there's going to be some substance to
that story in general but when i see
gotham knights it just it doesn't hit
right like at all all right but that was
specifically to show you just those two
characters right because they've already
had a trailer before
right so yeah i don't know i liked it
okay yeah i mean i'm not saying it looks
incredible i think it looks fine you
know it doesn't you know
yes it looks kind of like last gen kind
of but
yeah i think it looks like it's fine
it's fine i mean it's fine
we got 385 people in here man hit that
like button if you guys don't mind let's
get that over 200 likes before the end
of the show forte yo
tell me a game that you feel is going to
be there and it's going to be announced
most likely the third person third uh
third party and then tell me a game that
you feel microsoft needs to pursue and
it needs to be there okay cool let's do
this let's go
outriders world slayer needs to be in
there it needs to be it's already in
there is it did they put no where's what
you got to pay for
but i i could have sworn i saw the
little thing change and it says
i think you have to pay for that i might
be wrong but you shouldn't have to pay
microsoft don't listen to this dude
don't get that game
no that needs to be in there because uh
they need to do a men's for all the
problems we have with it
i agree i think saints row needs to be
in there saints oh
comes out in august august 23rd get you
ready for the holiday season get you
ready for uh you know get you lead up
towards um starfield and all the other
games coming out will because i think
forest is going to come out of september
so i think that's going to lead you
right into it so that would be like
you're really big
so saints row i definitely think should
be in there um who remembers test drive
that was available on where xbox live
blew up and stuff when it came to racing
and stuff i remember test driving test
drive they got the new test drive coming
out touchdrive solar power that's coming
out this um i think this um october or
september is coming out i think that
should be in there and then i also think
i'm with you guys got them nice i think
that should definitely be a game that
should be in there or they should go
after but let's be for real
i don't care if they don't own
activision yet i don't care about none
of that stuff i'm gonna stay some of
those they should go ahead modern
warfare 2 is literally coming out this
year yeah and you should put that game
he stole my one man
and the last dude steals
that's
it
moderate warfare that would be big
though
absolutely should be a gay pass
no go ahead first yeah so do you think
the current agreement they have it was
done years ago with sony right so do we
think that it i don't think nothing to
do with game pass though yeah so if it
doesn't say you can't be on yet you're
right
right they could they could work that
deal with activision and say and are
they really giving money to the
activision at that point they're just
giving back to themselves
something blaze is in the chat
no one be disrespectful to blaze he's
just in here it's chatting today blazes
go people who say playstation
playstation trash my dude look you can
keep the stuff like that uh i don't mind
the little back and forth because blaze
lives for that but let's not i don't
want it to elevate anything higher than
that let's let's let's be let's be
respectful and let's be respectful all
right so here let's man i'm sorry i saw
yours man we got through hargy and i was
like yes got you dirt and i was like
it's over then you're gonna steal my
stuff man and i gave you a bonus one
with uh say spro that's a good one i
like that saints row one though i really
like that one i kind of forgot about it
but anybody that thinks they shouldn't
get call of duty in there this holiday
is tricking themselves ooh that will be
fire bro i don't know if it's possible
listen i am not listen i am not the
biggest call of duty fan no more but my
favorite one was modern warfare 2 and i
ain't going to lie when i saw that
emblem when they showed it uh last week
i was like oh i'm definitely there today
and your forte but the one in 2019 the
modern warfare that was amazing that was
no it was it was really good campaign
you didn't mind a word for two though
yeah
here's how i feel like they're gonna go
um
i feel like okay
i don't know why we're gonna already get
on now
no i'm still saying the call of duty
because i don't care what you say
i feel like that's the bottom line call
of duty was going to be my going to be
there and the reason i feel like that is
because i feel that is a good way of
showing we don't own them but we own
them
right
i don't know if they can do that now i
do remember if you guys
recall
when they bought bethesda they put doom
in there the next like the next week
immediately yeah they did yeah and
what's funny is there were some games
that left that went right back in yeah
like dishonored i think i think fallout
4 also had left and went right back in i
believe so it would be interesting if
they can pull some strings and get that
taken care of the game i feel like they
need they need that persona game pass
coming in their day
announcement to be honest with you
even if they can't get that in their uh
in game pass they need that game at the
show it's some form of fashion right
yeah i feel like persona is one of the
few games
that shows
the different libraries of playstation
and if they get that not only are they
showing that they're trying to support
the japanese market but they're showing
we are working and we're getting some of
the games that doesn't normally come to
our platform uh they came up there and
they did an entire montage to stuff
that's not on our platform they showed
final fantasy vii up there dr uh some of
the older dragon quests up there um uh
trousers are still up there they they
show persona and they said all this is
coming game pass day and date i might
have a heart attack i might not be on
the next episode but you know i just
feel like
i need something
something even if it's not in game pass
i need something at this event
as a japanese center thing all right so
let's
we're we've got like two topics left uh
the next thing i want to talk and i know
i get made fun of for this a lot i get
made fun for this a lot
i personally feel like
what it would a platform holder opens
and closes with is important that's my
personal opinion because i feel like if
you're if you're opening
with something that you're looking at
like
why are you going to realistically think
the rest of the show is going to be good
at that point so like all right so
i want to ask you all what is a game
that you think they're going to open it
a game you think they're going to close
it and what is the game you think is
going in the middle that maybe you
didn't expect let's start
with forte what is the game you think is
going to open it close it in a game in
the middle uh open the show i do think
and i don't want to steal it from you
but i i was thinking this i think brett
fallon is going to start the show
because i think that's the one thing
that everybody's like where the heck is
this game coming you ain't talked about
it i do think that's going to be the
opener
um the starfield thing in the middle is
really interesting i don't know let's
let's go around for open and then we'll
go to them okay so i think for opening i
do think i do think red fall will open
the show because i think they end of the
show they should start a show and
especially with that gang that game is
literally supposed to come out around
that time like around the summertime so
yeah
i think that's the game that they're
going to start the show with just to let
people like oh yeah remember that game
here it is
all right so hargy man you know yeah
red fall that's what forte put his
stacks on you know i'm i'm gonna write
these down we could we gonna revisit
this who was right who was wrong
so hargy yeah what are they opening
microsoft with what are we seeing
exclusive on that on that screen maybe
not exclusive maybe they open with call
of duty saying it's in game pass day i
don't know i mean so like the dream
scenario would be uh abk finalized
own it [ __ ]
[Laughter]
they they just do the acting engine but
there's the round table on the order
totally microsoft come on the stage so
they bought everything yeah right oh we
bought uh sega we bought uh valve
no matter what they did okay hold up
imagine imagine they do another phil
spencer when he went up there and he
announced a ninja theory playground
games like that labs but
we really like the sonic franchise we
really like the persona franchise
he's like we had a huge relationship
with assassin's creed when it launched
on the xbox series x so we bought them
[Laughter]
now that would be crazy no but i think i
think it's going to start with starfield
um
what did they start with last time was
it starfield
yeah yeah they started with starfield i
think they're going to start with
starfield because i think that's the
thing they want to like
the the image of the show right the logo
it's starfield right so that's that's
going to be the thing that starts it to
me i think that's where it's going to go
all right dirk what are they starting
this with man you know i honestly think
they're going to start off with a new ip
compulsions new game they're going to
start off with that
that's that's realistic uh you know
what's crazy i love the state let's take
a second i love the state xbox is in
well we all didn't say the same damn
thing hats off to microsoft
congratulations that's boston listen hey
hold on let me tell you attic forte they
beat our legs last well they beat my
legs last generation xbox one
the ponies were goblin galloping on our
way thinking guys beat my legs last
iteration xbox didn't give us no ammo so
it's good to see they have something for
us to talk about nice
so uh do want to black legs
do you want to read this uh super chat
we got a two dollar super chat from an
uh antoine williams yep uh i think they
will start the stream sick uh so uh no
no
all right so
he wants to he's saying she wants to
show it right not start with it i hope
not i don't even want to show up with it
no don't start so let's let's do show it
let's do a middle shot i'm sorry let's
so
dirt
what do you think's gonna be in the
middle of the show that you know and
what's funny is there's so many games
that could be here that anything could
be in the middle yeah um i'm going to
say
you know what i don't know who said it
earlier but i think starfield might be
in the middle just like because y'all
last year i don't know if you guys
remember halo infinite was in the middle
so i believe starfield could possibly be
in the middle
that's going to be interesting yep
all right so
hargy man
tell me man what i hope they don't use
starfield as the is the middle sandwich
man i really hope they don't do that but
if they do they they do that what do you
think's going to be in the middle hard i
think it's red ball that's going to be
in the middle because i think they're
going to do near the end this like
reveal for
uh motorsport i shouldn't say but that's
going to be my thing at the end
right near the end the end of the show
of course i want to
something new but whatever okay forte
tell me man what do you think middle of
the show you said mm-hmm
middle of the show i think it's going to
be forza
forza that i think forza 8 is going to
be for the motorsport it's going to be
the middle of the show
that would be interesting all right so
i i um
i didn't do my beginning did i
no you didn't oh yeah i keep getting so
focused on you guys i completely forgot
i think they're going to open
the i think they're going to open with
the battle uh the
the halo battle royale they're going to
open with that
oh
yeah i think they're going to open with
the halo battery and i think the middle
i think the middle will be starfield
i mean i think starfield is going to be
closer to i think
i think it'll be the end like see
there's an end but then there's an end
i think it's the closest to the end i
think it's going to be like how forza
because you got to think because forza
was the thing that was the almost the
end but then they did red fall i think
starfield's going to be the same thing
it's going to be the thing right it's
going to be the last game they show
right before that yeah what we're seeing
we do now i want to keep in mind more i
was about to say we'll go ahead and go
into it uh now we're going to go into
the end ones and i want to there's a
little chariot here like this doesn't
mean it's the end of the show it just
means it's going towards towards the end
because i do believe that the uh the
fables the red falls those are mic drop
moments those are the ones that they
think is going to be a mic draw so
that's what that's going to be the next
one but what do you think is the sh the
game that's going to end the show
go
start with dirt let's start with dirt
quickity i believe whatever the
coalition is working on
whether it's gears you know we're
hearing they might be working on a
little smaller ip a new ip or whatever i
think whatever the coalition is working
on way in the show
okay argue what what do you think will
end it before they do the mic drop
moment
before they do the microphone yes porza
that's going to be forza forza that
that's a safe thing i i feel like they
could easily do that what do you think
forte what are they going to end this
with
uh i think a vowed
actually i agree with you i think it's
going to be a valve
all right mic drop moments we all love
mic drop moments man we all love them
uh you know and keep in mind this could
be the end the middle the beginning i do
feel like the majority of the time they
use this for the end but sometimes with
like the xbox backwards compatibility
that was the mic drop moment that year
so i'm gonna go through you guys tell me
what your biggest mic drop moment is
that you would think and the one you
think is realistic because we know
there's two there's two different types
of microphones there's two different
lights so
harji tell me what is a realistic mic
drop moment and what is one that would
be towards you to you
well so we hear some potential out of
bethesda or a star wars multiplayer type
game right
that could be an interesting mic drop
moment right to announce here we got a
star wars exclusive
right exclusive
exclusive game pass exclusive
right
um and i think the like
unrealistic one is uh you know they do
something with a superhero
and bring out one of those as a you know
a spider-man type game
and it's sad that we're saying that's
unrealistic but anyway forte tell me
what is a realistic one what and a
realistic mic drop moment and un not
even an unrealistic one but one that you
feel is that would be towards you like
something that i wouldn't care about but
you would care about because it it it
gives every box that you want
oh um i think
the mic we already i already said what
my mic drop mode is going to be i think
modern warfare 2 being in game pass is
going to be the might brought moment i
think that's going just destroy the
freaking shell
that would be incredible bro that's
enough to tell you that i think that's
just gonna destroy the show um for me
personally
um
if they
who see i'm a huge blizzard fan
huge blizzard fan i just want blizzard
to be blizzard again
um
i would love to see
for me that might drop level would be
diablo 4 actually seeing it i mean i saw
we saw gameplay of it already but diablo
4 being at the show with a release date
when it's actually coming out that would
be my personal my drop moment
that's interesting all right so
they're getting man
tell me
what is
tell me what yours is because
they being a little unrealistic here i'm
joking i'm joking with you guys what is
your you know i want this because it's
because i'm selfish kind of movement and
what is yours okay it's a safe move
they're going to do it we all know
they're going to do it mike dropbox
you know i got to be honest man
both of mines are unrealistic to me but
hold on
okay
i will say the mic drop moment would be
they go on stage and
kojima comes out right that rumored
kojima game oh yeah that would be it's
announced
right that's a mic drop moment for me
and um like you said it might drop
moment and what's the second thing you
say
and just
something that you feel it would be a
mic drop moment but it's just it's not
necessarily safe but
microsoft's doing it and it's going to
wow you
but it's not something that you would
not have expected like something that
you kind of would have expected yeah
that's like both of them to me is the
coach even thing like i'm not
a huge kojima guy but i gotta be honest
with you addict i gotta be honest with
you forte
target
i'm sorry is it hard get
hot
sorry
i gotta be honest with you guys
them announcing kojima gang
it is ammunition
for me because i have
a folder in my phone my gallery
a playstation fanboy saying kojima would
never work with xbox ux bots are
delusional to think that he will work
with xbox on an exclusive game so i'm
just being honest with you guys yes i
would love to see that
now well um someone in the chat let me
bring them up real quick said
the panel totally forgot the part where
phil spencer comes out and gives a
speech usually
the mic drop moment is a relation of the
speech it's related it's related to the
speech he'll be like it is one more
thing
yeah so okay let me get these super
chats real quick and then i'll go
through mine oh you know another oh you
know what i just thought about that kyla
bunga collection for um the ninja
turtles games that should be a game pass
oh that would be nice that that what i
was thinking about i was like what else
could i say that would is a realistic
game it should be a game pass yeah
absolutely
so we got a two dollar spirits from
carlos they will show halo br from
certain affinity i do think that might a
good chance i'll be there
we got five dollar super chat from
negative zero i think right fall is
going to re uh
regate
relegate to summer game fest i base the
prediction off of an advertisement
cesaro for uh summer game show i
actually do think you'll see the sea
thieves the red fall i think that might
be at the game
fast i i think
there's a good chance you might not even
said riff see red fall at the event
because they're going to give it to uh
uh to jeff and as much as i disagree
with that i understand and then you know
definitely put that icon in the in the
chat man welcome flush jacks into the
realm put those icons in there give him
that uh that that good welcoming all
right so here's what okay look i know
we're gonna disagree with this all right
i think my
moment
that i thought would be a mic draw
moment is if he comes up there
and says they bought either
square enix or sega
that would be my mic drop moment because
i feel like
in a swoop they have secured
the right to say that they are taking
japanese support seriously and i feel
like until you buy at least a studio
make a studio or go above and beyond to
get some of these games into game pass
or just get these games to come to game
pass in general you're not going to
fully get saul like you're taking it
serious
so i feel like that's going to be and
you know as far as
a mic drop moment i think indiana jones
i think that would actually surprise
people at the end if they saw an indiana
jones
or you know fable fable would be a mic
drop moment if you saw in-depth good
gameplay
fable would be a good moment but
what i want to really point out and uh
let me get this uh we got a super chat
from dead planet
mic drop xbox swipe silent metal gear
solid that's actually interesting uh
i think i think some uh some people on
twitter would have a meltdown if that
happened
but
xbox has really never been in this kind
of situation before uh you know we went
through a lot of different scenarios and
what i liked about it
past years we all said the same thing oh
they're gonna open with fours so they're
gonna end with gears they're gonna open
with fours they're gonna end with hazel
very few of us have the same damn
opening i don't know if it's because you
don't want to copy me i know i i know
people care about you
so you know maybe you didn't want to
copy each other but we all had different
things and they were feasible and
realistic
so it shows that the brand is doing
better it's just
do you want to wait for some of these
games no i i actually agree badger kazoo
would be a mic drop moment to me but i'm
starting to forg i'm starting i'm
starting to get to the point where i'm i
i i'm not a believer just not
um i think killer async might be out
there you know just because we didn't
say some of these doesn't mean that
they're not going to be there
it's just
i don't think there's any huge fighter
fans on this panel is there
i mean no yeah so i mean why would i
care about something i ain't going to
play now i know k mega that's his back
i'm sure he won
but i don't care so
you know i would be happy for k megan to
get his bag but damn it i want my bag
too what's going on
i want my fable
uh and you know regardless we probably
ain't gonna see fable it's just nice to
see the brand in such a good lighting
uh so you know let's do our last
last thoughts on
your overall expectations on the show
and where you think this could elevate
uh and and how important you think this
show is we're gonna start with hard guy
how important do you think this show is
that we're getting into
and what could happen
if they do a really good job showing it
and i feel like do you think they're
going to highlight on gameplay
um are they gonna highlight gameplay of
the games that they've announced if if
they're bringing stuff in then i would
say yes they're gonna do that um
so
as far as like what they need to do here
is establish the roadmap right so
they've got a lot of momentum there's
issues with sony and production levels
so that's diminishing their you know
sales for ps5
a microsoft for the beginning of the
year has been outselling them right
they could keep that going but they need
to give people a reason to stay with
this platform and that's what they need
to do here set that roadmap for the next
two to three years here's the stuff
you're gonna be playing all of it's
coming to game pass
you're gonna want to be on this
subscription over spartacus come to our
side right that is what they need to do
with this show that that i think is the
overall theme
dirt
what what do you think man i agree with
what he just said this show is extremely
important
um like he just mentioned you know
playstation they're having issues with
stock shortages and things like that and
it looks like it might continue a little
while longer
and xbox needs to take advantage of that
to show the content you know they showed
a lot of trailers before
in 2020 and 2021 now it's time to show
some gameplay for these games
and it's extremely important man because
content is king and we all know how you
know xbox they had years where they just
really didn't have anything
those days are gone um
and the future is very bright so they
have to show some some like we mentioned
earlier adding some release years or
just some windows of when these some of
these big big games are dropping and and
also
i know people hate xbox game pass i know
people tired of us talking about xbox
game pass how great of a service it is
but that's what it is it's a great
service
and word of mouth about xbox game pass
needs to continue and if this show
shows off everything um that we're
thinking they're gonna show off you know
including gameplay including you know
third-party games dropping the xbox game
past day one i believe they need to yell
from the rooftops yo
game players is the place you need to be
because we have these quality games and
this service for 15 to 10 a month so
yeah
that's what i'm thinking it's a very
important show though
okay so forte man
what do you think do you do you think
it's just an average show that even if
they bomb this they'll still be fine
because i
people keep forgetting that like
we talk about stuff the gaming industry
news is so fast
you can drop the ball and be fine in a
week but sometimes
it lasts a little longer yes the last
generation would that's why i want you
like the last of the whole generation
right so how do you feel forte do you
feel like this is an important
event for e3 do you think it's just one
of those things where
it's just a stepping stone how do you
feel
i think it's important for me
and i think it's important for people on
this panel
because we're the ones that's been
on the ground floor
for almost it feels like a decade at
this point it does feel like that
so
we
i mean you know
it really just comes down you support
the platform
for different reasons um
it's like i'm tired of telling people
the reason i play on xbox is just
because of my friends
because that's really the reason why at
this point because the games
really haven't been there it's the
ecosystem it's where all my where all my
my community is where my friends are so
that's the reason i play on xbox
i'm tired of that being the reason i
wanted to be more subsident to that i
wanted to be because they showed us
great experiences i want to feel like
the system i bought
isn't just
of a vehicle to play with just certain
people
you know that's that's what i kind of
want xbox to change the narrative on we
always know that it's about you know the
ecosystem is about friends it's about
community
but we always skip over the one thing
that the system is the most important
thing about which is the games so
this year for them is very important for
me
is it a make or break for them no the
reason is not to make or break for them
is because game pass is so incredible
it's going to be that thing that's going
to supersede what anybody thinks about
the show in general all that because
once the games start hitting that
service who cares about what they show
as long as the games are good that's all
that really truly matters
but
i just want to get past the
wait for e3 because we're at another one
right now
wait for e3 i want to get past that so
for me personally
i just want to see xbox take the next
step
in order to
feel like they got that proverbial
monkey off their back like yo we can
finally breathe easy we people know what
the plan is people know what the content
delivery is going to look like and i
think they took a small step in that
direction last year at e3
but then they dropped the ball
with all the halo stuff at the end of
the year so they kind of had to reset
again
now it's time to reprove yourself and
that's why i think starfield is the most
important thing they have there because
that's pretty much their halo moment
from last year
they can't let starfield take away all
the great momentum that they have built
up throughout the second half of this
year going into this event
culminating with the game coming out the
end of the year if they can hit all
those notes right they can show people
the games and the experiences they want
to see at e3 this year or at the
bethesda software microsoft
collaboration part two before activision
shows up thing i think they'll be
perfectly fine and i think they're gonna
do that
but for me i just want to see them
address the one elephant in the room
which is games
and nothing but games that's it i agree
with you i think this is an important uh
showcase for them because
it represents we we're buying these
companies well we're investing heavily
in the game pass and it represents but
we haven't lost
the focus of gaming yes it's not just
about buying studios and taunting that
you know we could put these on game pass
it's not about just making sure call of
duty could be on game pass day and date
overwatch being game pass day day it's
about elevating the industry in general
making gaming better overall for
everyone
and about
we're investing into these studios to
make better games than not just make
games for us
and i feel like you're gonna see that
with star filled you know sure i don't
think starfield's gonna be the prime
example of what bethesda
can do for microsoft under microsoft's
brand because
a lot of starfield was already done but
it does show
that bethesda has hit a hundred percent
the past couple years especially with
like fallout 76 and it shows that they
can get back on track and then you'll
see
red fall regardless if you like that
type of
it's just some gameplay aren't going to
like it and i do feel like this shows
we are still in this to win and we're
still in this to deliver
quality games to you and we could do
both and i feel like that is what this
is really about um i feel like we're
going to see game pass stuff on here i
feel like we're going to see gameplay i
don't think we're going to see a lot of
cgi
right i think we'll see some
but i think in the past we've seen 25
gameplay 75 cgi i think you're going to
flip that i think you're realistically
going to flip that you're going to see a
couple games getting announces as cgi
but i do think you're going to see
a vowel game play hopefully unless like
i said it's towards the end of next year
then you might see it as like the video
game awards or next year's event in
general and i think you're going to
start seeing the gameplay that we've
seen i know i know that there was rumors
that
every microsoft studio has made
content for this event
uh regardless that doesn't mean that
it's being used at this event it could
be used for
uh uh
jeff's event it could be used for the
video game awards it could be used for
maybe an exo event in the future i don't
think that means that they're making it
just for this event
but i'm excited and i think everyone in
the chat should be excited i get it
we've waited a long time for this and i
get it people say we'll keep waiting for
the next event the next event the next
event
well the next defense in a month
right and at this point if we've waited
this long what's another month
uh so you know i appreciate it for
coming through i know that this wasn't
exactly what i advertised
but guess what
i'm not exactly what i advertise half
the time so i appreciate everyone for uh
for chillin i think we had a fantastic
show broke down the show for the most
part um you know and i think because i'm
missing some of the people your boy
might do another one next week this is
with a different set of panel members
because i want hustle to be part of it i
want tim dog to be part of it and
because i couldn't get them on this one
i might do it next week with maybe like
diller gaming and cody's but i don't
know we'll see but i'm not promising
that i'm just saying it might happen i
got to see what's going on tim dawg said
he wants to come on next week uh but
we'll see how it goes uh but you know i
appreciate ever coming through man it
was a great show
forte where can the people find you
what's that dps going for you man yeah
man uh great show attic uh as always man
shout out to you and the iron lords for
putting on an amazing show like you
always do no matter what shout out to
hustle can't be here tim dawg everybody
else uh for myself gave me forte you
already know you can meet me youtube
twitter xbox live playstation all of
those places uh dps podcast is tomorrow
night
nine p.m on my channel with the homeboy
slumber backslap it's gonna be a great
time we are being joined by erica's for
the win her first time coming over to
the show so
make sure you um come over and support
her you know in motherhood and
everything because you know it's about
to hit the hit the rocks on that one but
uh yeah this is a great show appreciate
it make sure you go check out all of
these guys man they do great content
every last one of them shout out to you
guys and you guys have a great week and
enjoy the games you're playing
all right then you know we got hargey
sidney let me tell you something i hit
this man up 20 minutes before the show
started
20 minutes and it's nice that you showed
up here you know you got a youtube
channel hearty what's going on with that
man yes tell the people to go and get in
there yeah so game on daily.com of
course check that site out and then we
have our game on daily go live every
saturday at 4 p.m eastern uh so check
that out as well
and don't you got a personal channel i
do but i put very little on there you're
welcome to go to my channel it's just
johnny on youtube yeah go there
most of my new stuff will actually be on
on game on daily's uh youtube channel so
shout out check it out we got it
you know he doesn't have a twitter i
think he needs to change that
[Laughter]
well see maybe if elon buys it maybe
it'll be better i don't know i still
think it's going to suck i think
twitter's horrible
all right so
then we got the one the only
dirt griggety what's what would you be
doing here lately sir i'm lazy man
crying about getting my legs kicked in
last generation but you know besides
that i just mean you know just having
fun man you know uh check out my
podcast on monday evenings at 6 30 p.m
eastern time uh called wbg xbox podcast
yes yes we talk a lot of trash i must
admit
we have a lot of fun though uh you know
so stop by check it out you know we do
the podcast also my my little videos
while i'm crying about last generation
and things like that so just stop on by
man this house let's have a little time
and you know
florida addicts here definitely catch us
on the iron lords podcast this sunday at
1pm
i don't know if i'm allowed to tell
people the guest
but i'm going to do it anyway do it
anyway let's go
let's go we might have a certain
person on the podcast
feels like
no it's not going to be an executive
well we
aaron
no it's it's a it is a content creator
slash developer that's all going to give
you any types of
uh content creators conte creator slash
developer
everyone in this chat knows who he is
okay i know you're talking about what
are you talking about now i'm not going
to tell the name but if you can put two
and two together yeah it isn't
it okay i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
confirm or deny anything in the chat man
you already know who this is
jeff was he was he was he on um gamers
talk live on the sunday
yes he was oh
comfortable but that that has not you
know that could be a coincidence too man
that could be a coincidence too so you
know if all goes well hopefully we have
we will have this individual on the
podcast like it's looking like it's
going to be a solid going through but
joe biden i'm done with you guys well
it's good we know it's him because he
straight he straight professed all his
love during the five question segment
saying i didn't
definitely catch the iron lords podcast
at 1 pm this sunday
like i said hopefully we'll have this
individual on the podcast
man that's going to be interesting he
swears up a storm
i'm not confirmed
he's he's on it okay so and then i did
review i didn't chronicle rising it's on
the the channel you're currently
watching this on it's on game pass too
so you know if you if you think it's
worth your time to go watch to see if
the game itself is worth downloading
definitely go there and check that out i
am currently reviewing another game it
isn't in game pass but you will see that
probably here in the next week and a
half and i appreciate it for coming
through until next time this is gaming
addicts and that's another attic show
peace
we gone
deuces